what's up guys welcome to IG likes i'm
justine and this is the show where i
recap cool things that happened this
past week and show them to you here in
this video first up our videos that i
like this week and i'm really excited
about this first one i've heard Josh
Sundquist does the serious called
things for math nerds he did and I just
seen version and this video is a hundred
percent better than all of my videos put
together
other early viral videos include a vlog
about how much she wants a hamburger and
another about wanting a pizza link in
the description so go check out his
video and leave a comment and let him
know which of my videos is your favorite
this next video pretty much took over my
entire Facebook and Twitter feed
especially for my friends in New York
thanks see the infamous graffiti artist
who has works that sell for upwards of
millions of dollars a lot of dollars set
up a sidewalk shop having this guy who
sat around and yond the entire time sell
his official signed pieces of work for
$60 one of the women that actually
bought one of the pieces even negotiated
half off for two of the paintings one of
those things where we kind of take for
granted things that are just around us
in our everyday lives you know stop and
smell the roses type moments or stop and
buy a two hundred thousand seven hundred
and fifty thousand painting for $60 kind
of thing smells like a deal to me
there's actually a few weeks old with a
Minecraft South Park episode I cannot
stop thinking about it and I will just
be sitting there and I will start
laughing if anybody has seen at the
cable TV part
I don't want to spoil it if you haven't
seen it but if you haven't I recommend
you go and watch even if you've never
played minecraft I love it it South Park
whose are freaking just absolute
geniuses and I love you can I be a voice
I will even say swear words I don't care
I will do whatever you want in gaming
news all you guys have been talking
about is Pokemon X&Y which had a global
release and sold over 4 million copies
worldwide in two days not gonna lie I
don't actually play Pokemon and never
really got into it but what I do really
get into Grand Theft Auto freaking just
love this game this past weekend I went
to London for gfinity which is a Call of
Duty tournament this is their second one
the last one they had a few months ago
and congratulations to complexity yet
again they've come in first place in
both tournaments so hopefully in g3 not
that I don't want you guys to win I
think you guys should let somebody else
have a chance it's only the right thing
to do maybe I'll start a team maybe I
won't I've also been thinking of
rebooting my minecraft server I know you
guys used to absolutely love hanging out
on it so if that's something that you'd
be interested in it thumbs up will leave
me a comment winking is so stupid I've
been gearing up for the new consoles
PlayStation 4 or Xbox one guys which one
do you want which one are you get I just
redid my little gaming setup to prepare
and make room I will do a proper video
and show you guys my setup here soon but
not in this video
moving right along to IG book club I'm
super excited because I actually just
got this book it is the everything store
Jeff Bezos and the age of Amazon because
honestly everything that I buy it's on
Amazon me and my UPS guy like this he
knows me my name he's seen every single
pair of my pajama pants cuz that's all I
ever wear on that note if this is a book
that you guys would be interested in
check it out on audible.com slash
iJustine you can get a free book you
guys buy now should know the drill I'm
gonna put a link in the description so
you'll get a 30 day free trial plus a
free freaking book let me know what book
you guys get I feel like
I have so many projects for you guys in
this video let me know which book you
get audible.com slash I've just seen Go
Go Go it's your birthday it's about my
birthday
next Oh beauty and style oh my god I'm
so fashionable i disgust myself i'm not
fashionable but what I did do was do a
little Sephora shopping and I picked up
this Laura Mercier skin cream foundation
I use a lot of Laura and Bobby Brown I
decided to switch it up a little bit
because I have been using a lot of Bobby
Brown Dacian and has sunscreen and then
I definitely recommend wearing sunscreen
but sometimes I'm sitting around my
house you just don't need those extra
chemicals on your face so this has no
sunscreen also wearing this I never do
press powders I always do like loose
powders but I saw this and I thought I
would just give it a little try because
when I mama go lose powder kind of sucks
but this is also Laura smooth finish
foundation powder so it's kind of like
foundation powder I hate wearing
concealer so these together pretty much
act as a concealer so I like to just to
have a little here to have a little here
but you don't to use too much because it
is powder so it will dry out your skin
just make sure you moisturize moisturize
moisturize you guys always ask what
lipstick I wear I don't actually wear
lipstick this is pretty much what I
always wear freakin the best chapstick
and last but not least this is going to
be used for a fall a fashion video baby
the color of fall
orange lipstick is a must so what are
these lame doubt shadow pencils guess
what color of fall incoming I can't wait
to do this video well my friends that's
it for IJ likes I hope you guys enjoyed
the episode I believe I gave you a bunch
of things to do in this episode so
hopefully you remember them all if not
I'll do a recap in the description make
sure you get your free book check out
josh's video
what else did I have for you to do I
don't know I'm gonna have to rewatch
this video and figure it out I love you
I'll see you soon
don't forget to subscribe and that's all
see ya